[Musique]
actualité artistique à présent avec un
concert de musique électro acoustique
donné hier soir à malakoff au centre
rené rousseau concert inattendu à plus
d'un titre
claude samuel assistait à la dernière
mise au point
[Musique]
nous sommes ici dans un gymnase une
salle de concert vous avez quelque chose
contre les salles de concerts
traditionnels peut-être on pourrait le
penser puisque presque à chaque
conscience je donne mais j'ai cherché un
lieu correspondant à la valeur des sons
à la au climat que je sais et ce gymnase
pour moi me rappeler un peu la salle de
l'alhambra à bordeaux vous ai fait un
concert coucher des enfants c'est aussi
parce que c'est un concert au sol les
aventures au sol un concert au choix y
aussi les pour 2.81 celui ci un public
assis sur les gradins est plus attirant
le regard d'un doublé contre les cochons
les mieux entraînées clichés on est
mieux surtout pour la première oeuvre
gymkhana qui était fait pour être
entendu au sol signé sur des
magnétophones et du groupe de hauts
parleurs donc une bonne famille à ses
premières
[Musique]
pourquoi il ya eu tellement de balles on
voit énormément de ballons en femme et
bien les ballons qu'on a mis des
environnements
pour à la fois projeté tout un matériel
dizaine pour cérémonie et ensuite pour
traiter la salle d'accouchement
l'offre non de la création de vous cette
semaine à malakoff s'intitule gymkhana
jour où il ya un parcours automobile
dans ce que j'aime canon mais c'est un
parcours électroacoustique internet ici
un parcours du combattant les gens qui
seront couchés vous entendre une
polyphonie est classée avec des
obstacles bizarre avec tout ce qui se
rapporte à gilles kahn est ensuite j'ai
fait ça pour le volet gymnase de
circonstance et vous le chef d'orchestre
aux manettes et moi le monde
est-ce que vous pensez que la musique
électroacoustique c'est l'avenir et que
dans un avenir plus ou moins lointain il
n'ira plus que de la musique
électroacoustique et les musiciens
traditionnels et bien non rien à faire
non je ne crois pas qu'il y aura
d'ailleurs tout ce qui est musique
classique puisqu'il répertoire tiendra
toujours je crois que l'ennemi des
produits électro acoustique et
électronique
peut-être la musique de l'avenir pour
les compositeurs de l'avenir mais il y
aura toujours de la place pour les
musiciens souvent tistes enfin je crois
non et vous pensez qu'une connexion
entre sept types de musique et notre
civilisation c'est la musique de notre
époque
il me semble c'est ce que je pense moi
c'est ce que je sens en moi
[Musique]